you know what movie we started but we
haven't finished but so far it's really
good it's I think you know we're not
going to talk about it cuz we can't even
get through the first ten minutes we
couldn't because it was about right yep
King back through that movie
don't even mention the movie until we
see it okay give it justice all right
you've seen it you've never seen any of
those movies right my first one ever and
also because it's the first time I saw
that actor Javier Bardem was No Country
for Old Men yes I was like my first time
seeing a movie great movie whoa this is
a great introduction to their movies all
together but what movie you have to see
which is along that land of the same
lines is Blood Simple their very first
one but I've never seen it Blood Simple
is a [ __ ] masterpiece and it's done
with what $10 really I mean you can tell
that it's not but you can tell the day
milk every camera angle and every choice
yeah it's it's it's an amazing [ __ ]
movie what is your favorite Wes Anderson
movie oh god that's a tough one but I
would have to say the Royal Tenenbaums
is your favorite director I have I have
top tens and he's in my top 10 my
favorite ever ever is Life Aquatic
nothing beats water anything or just
like the that whole movie from beginning
to end is like a dream come true for me
on screen yeah it makes me so happy I
don't know why what's the camp one with
Edward Norton no that's moonlight King
it's moonrise King I mean there's it's
it's like I you know what you're right
in 2017 I want to grow and I I want to
accept the fact that not everyone seen
everything and that you grew up in a
different time period you know you're
also 20 years older than I understand
that but can I just say this and I've
heard that argument many many times is
is that high and low Kurosawa's movie
was that made in the 50s I saw it I
wasn't alive then I'm just one of those
guys it's good
oh yeah as a kid I'll watch it because I
didn't like you know at that time when
in the 80s
you saw sixteen Candles is fun then you
see a [ __ ] Lanka Kong on it you mean
you know yeah but you're whatever he
says in it you know I mean and then you
want to see something Asians doing cool
things yeah looking handsome
you know solving crimes yeah that's all
but for as much as you know about movies
it really really surprises me that you
know nothing about so you're very kind
of boy well we had times 42 because it
talks about what a great movie buff he
is right then he puts us all down if we
don't know like you know a single movie
but this is the guy who says he's a cell
he's a self-proclaimed movie buff that
he knows so much more than us but he
can't even name one bedroom on one of
our movie just one name one flutterfly
oh god you see what I'm saying Pedro
almodóvar is one of the most world
renowned directors you don't know but
you're gonna continuously talk about
Kurosawa curse hour but you know you
know nothing about me I'm gonna look up
now you [ __ ] you really just pissed
me off so bad really I know he's gonna
learn everyone know I'm gonna say this
I'm gonna say top 20 directors of all
time directors of volta if he's on this
list yeah I will watch every single one
of his movies and I'm gonna apologize to
you every day for the next year
whoa okay top 20 directors of all time
publication are we going yeah in general
no not in general all right let's go
film comment
I bet he's down there okay so Phil here
we go all right IMDB no no you're gonna
get like very American sense yeah TV is
- American sitcom The Guardian The
Guardian is good okay where is the 40
best directors well I'll name the top 20
for you all right obviously mmm David
Lynch
Martin Scorsese Coen Brothers I'm here
Steven Soderbergh yes
Terrence Malick ah Abbas Kiarostami ah
you don't know him either Errol Morris
you know Errol Morris Hayao Miyazaki yes
David Cronenberg oh my god this is not
the right list Terence Davis there's no
way Lucas my modest Kurosawa's not even
on the front top 1000 name one one car
away movie if yours yeah I'm not
listening to this I don't live in this
land if you're such a movie buff at your
age right now
wait Kurosawa's not in this list he
probably is he's not he's not on this
list what I'm saying is is already the
wrong list name one one girl a movie and
there's no in the mood for love
Chungking Express Spike Jonze is on this
list and Chris I was not on this is not
the right Sergio Leone there's I mean
what the [ __ ] oh this is this this is
not the list I think these people are
all still alive yeah I'm not doing that
list [ __ ] that list just saying I'm just
calling you a guardian I'm the ultimate
list of all-time
IMDB that's what I'm doing number one
Steven Spielberg IMDB is American I
don't care Steven Spielberg is a great
[ __ ] directly yeah but you're gonna
miss out on our la source kz alfred
hitchcock I'm Arthur Stanley Kubrick yep
right those fans Francis Ford Coppola
okay right Billy Wilder okay Woody Allen
here we go John Huston Peter Jackson
Orson Welles see now we need to start
getting Milos Forman John Ford David
Lean Inger Inger in marburg Ingrid
Bergman Joel Coen Ridley Scott this is
already not cut Tarantino none of you
know bollywood directors what I'm saying
is stop sitting on your high horse
because you don't know everything Bobby
here we go this is a good way look he's
gonna try to still prove us wrong I am I
apologize I you know what
that's I don't know anything huh
and I was you know I was a slept king
but now I'm nothing because you know I
don't do I don't rip on Gilbert
because out of hate it's out of growth
and love
thank you but then it's like you have to
tear me down baby I don't know Allah
malabar leo I don't know I'm the other
guy
you know so let's just go to the
questions then question yeah I'm just
gonna say something just in general I'm
gonna change my ways okay
no I'm just saying and I just want to
say I want you to apologize to me
I need you to apologize for me I'm sorry
Bobby for what for not accepting the
growth that you were giving me and
that's exactly why I am this is love Kay
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
because he didn't even do anything wrong
and he apologized and that makes me the
[ __ ] king of but I think I'm whoa
right look at me right now man apologize
apologize for that how long it took me
I'm sorry [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]